on est dans une période historique quand
même dramatique avec de vraies urgences
on a un problème de production
industrielle on a un problème
d'inflation qui va dévaster une bonne
partie de la société française et le
gouvernement
mais
le désordre dans le pays on proposant
une réforme qui de mon point de vue mal
conçu n'a pas de sens et qui surtout
n'est pas urgente donc je suis en train
de me demander c'est pas le gouvernement
qui manifeste quand même mais c'est le
gouvernement c'est le gouvernement qui a
décidé de faire cette réforme à
contretemps de l'histoire et donc pour
moi
mais si vous voulez toute la présidence
d'Emmanuel Macron est associée au
désordre il m'arrive de penser que
Macron survit par le